hello everyone and welcome to GameSpot's
2014 coverage on Tomic shay and this is
kevin brown or right beside me Kevin you
played the strangest cooking sim on the
show floor it's called grey goo and it
is a simulation of your own experience
in the kitchen can you just tell us a
little bit but well you see my
refrigerators covered with this stuff
inside and I call it the grey goo
because it's sort of good no seriously
Chinese food in milk yeah so it's
actually a roll of real-time strategy
game RTS kids oh so it yes it is and
it's coming from petroglyph the people
well known for games like universe at
war and star wars empire at war so they
know there are tss and they're trying to
get back to the sort of old-school RTS
back back in the days when there were
lots of games that we're building on the
age of empires formula and on command
and conquer and on and on starcraft and
so on and so forth so this is the game
that really harks back to those days and
so you've got three different factions
and one of them is human one of them is
beta and one of them is called the goo
it's called grey goo and that's where
the title comes from now in in science
fiction parlons grey goo is basically
what happens when nanobots like just you
know take over the world basically in
everybody turned into the after effect
of Call of Duty advanced warfare yes
sort of okay yes and and so one of the
factions and this is the factor that I
played today in the playable demo was I
played as it the goo because I've never
really played anything like that and the
goo is a faction that does not have a
base so all of the units that you create
comes from this big blob of goo that you
can take around and to collect resources
you take their big thing of goo and go
over top of the resource and you
immediately collect them you don't have
to send out a unit to collect resources
for you you just take your think of the
booze maybe like a mobile base but
eventually the you split the goo so you
can split the goo and then more so many
euphemisms going on right I know right
but you split the goo and then you can
turn it into different units and they
can be you know they can be flying units
they can be ground units
and then you can also create more goos
and you can also like sort of upgrade
using a using a tech tree as well and
all of that stuff costs you the same
resources that you're collecting on the
map but there's no base building when
you play as the goo and it's really
interesting because the goo also besides
being sort of your mobile base where
everything comes from the goo is also
it's it's own attack unit like if you
order it to cross units like it will
just it will just suck them up and
dissolve them it's really cool to watch
so I had a lot of fun like I just played
against the AI I had eventually like I
had to base like I had two main GU units
like the mother boo as I think what they
actually call it and so I'm taking my
mother one mother goo around like
collecting resources and then splitting
off unit so I'm using the other GU is
like an attack unit and for upgrades and
stuff and so I'm taking around just like
just solving units and it was it was
actually a lot of fun and the game has a
really good sci-fi look to it you know I
like the way the the beta looks the beta
faction is really cool to look at too
and even the humans now nobody wants to
play humans are so boring but humans in
this game look really interesting
there's sort of your your turtling
faction so if you're into like staying
at the base and being defensive you're
human if you kind of want to split you
know between being aggressive and
defensive you play as the beta and if
you're totally aggressive you play as
the goo and you just like just get in
there you start moving you you can try
to rush although you have to be careful
because if you're you know like it might
be tempting to try to like Zerg the goo
if that's a thing I guess I could say
but if you try to zerg rush with your
your initial piece of goo you're going
to be in trouble because that's your own
only means of collecting resources it's
the only thing you have when you start
the game so is it might be tempting to
try to just send that goo out there but
okay probably not necessarily going to
function if you try to do that because
that things just that's Leslie you're
only thing you've got everything comes
from the goo
okay well thank you very much for giving
us all of the information remember that
advice everything comes from the goo
yeah keep watchin game bot where we
promise not to talk about goo in the
future